[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres il y a longtemps que nous
n'avons pas connu semblable désordre
mondial semblable menace y compris
nucléaire alors comment expliquer ces
désordres comment répondre à ces menaces
c'est le thème de cette émission le
nouveau désordre mondial et nous avons
invité deux auteurs qui sont bien mieux
que des experts d'abord un romancier et
les romanciers sont souvent des voyants
Giuliano dans police bonsoir bonsoir
vous avez publié chez Gallimard le mage
du Kremlin qui raconte Poutine son
entourage son ascension son exercice du
pouvoir et puis un acteur majeur de la
scène internationale puisqu'il a présidé
aux destiné de la la sixième puissance
mondiale François Hollande bonsoir
monsieur le Président vous publiez
bouleversement aux éditions Stock
c'est un livre qui est à la fois concis
précis pédagogique et qui explique les
désordres internationaux qui exposent
les menaces auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés qui esquissent des solutions
mais j'ai envie de vous poser une
d'abord une question personnelle lorsque
vous êtes arrivés à l'Élysée vous
n'aviez pas eu d'expérience
gouvernementales en tous les cas en
matière internationale quelle a été le
premier événement ou la première
rencontre qui vous a fait prendre
conscience de la gravité des enjeux et
qu'est-ce que vous ayez ce que vous avez
eu le vertige
non j'ai pas eu le vertige la première
rencontre réunion que j'ai eu l'honneur
d'effectueux de la France c'était un G8
et c'était aux États-Unis à Candide le
président russe de l'époque était maître
Poutine et c'était Obama qui présidait
les travaux et je me suis dit nous
sommes dans un monde où les 8 plus
grandes puissances sauf la Chine sont
réunies il y a une crise économique la
zone euro est déjà en très grande
instabilité est-ce que nous sommes
conscients de ce que nous avons comme
responsabilité et où est-ce que c'est
simplement un échange courtois que nous
allons avoir pendant deux jours
et c'est tout le problème des relations
internationales à quel moment
prenons-nous véritablement la mesure la
conscience qu'il y a des enchaînements
qui peuvent conduire à des catastrophes
ou à des désordres tels que nous les
vivants aujourd'hui mais juste un mot
anecdotique le président russe de
l'époque medvedef était en fin de
parcours puisque Poutine allait le BIS
succéder c'était leur arrangement et il
était d'une extrême modération
d'une extrême douceur j'avais envie de
lui dire mais écoutez vous êtes quand
même président de la Russie
exprimez-vous dites ce que vous pensez
mais non il était là comme si il était
déjà plus là on va revenir à tout ça
mais je voudrais qu'on commence notre
émission avec Giuliano daopoli et vous
réagirez monsieur le Président
Giuliano vous êtes chercheur en sciences
politiques vous avez été le conseiller
de Matteo Renzi président du Conseil
italien de centre gauche vous êtes
enseignant à Sciences et vous publiez un
livre le mage du Kremlin aux éditions
Gallimard qui est un roman sur
l'ascension de Poutine sur son exercice
du pouvoir je l'ai dit et qui est l'une
des choses les plus fantastiques que
j'ai lu au cours des dernières semaines
parce que l'efficacité littéraire n'a
d'égale que l'intérêt des analyses du
pouvoir que vous proposez simplement
vous n'êtes pas ruchologue vous n'êtes
pas romancier pourquoi diable avez-vous
choisi la forme du roman et comment vous
y êtes vous prie pour que ça paraisse si
vrai et si juste
écoutez merci d'abord pour vos parents
vous savez il y a plusieurs portes
d'entrée dans dans la Russie à mon avis
on peut y arriver à travers la
littérature on peut y arriver par
idéologie moi j'y suis arrivé parce que
la première fois que j'ai débarqué à
Moscou ce qui m'a frappé c'est la ville
au monde où on ressent le plus à mon
avis l'emprise du pouvoir pouvoir qui
émane de ce fossile du Kremlin au centre
de la ville et après ce disperse dans la
ville et ça m'a beaucoup frappé ça m'a
fait peur et au moment où j'ai terminé
mon expérience en effet de conseiller
politique j'avais envie d'écrire un
livre qui serait un livre sur le pouvoir
parce que après l'actualité un peu pris
le dessus sur ce côté mais au départ
c'était surtout ça alors justement vous
décrivez la sanction de Poutine à
travers un de ses conseillers Vadim
qui est un personnage de fiction mais
inspire d'un personnage à elle et vous
vous définissez une opposition entre
l'homme politique démocrate l'homme
d'État démocrate qui cherche le
consensus qui veut exprimer l'empathie
pour son peuple et l'homme d'État
autorité qui recherche l'ordre et qui
veut incarner la force et vous dites que
Poutine a compris
qu'à la fin des années 90 le peuple
russe attendait l'homme d'autorité oui
il faut il faut partir du chaos de la
Russie des années 90 évidemment où au
secours justement cette ville
d'habitude tenue par le pouvoir était
devenu une sorte de Disneyland pour
adulte armée de kalachnikov ou voilà la
violence était partout l'État était
infaillite n'arrivait plus à payer ni
les salaires ni les retraites etc et là
donc dans toute cette confusion émerge
effectivement un homme qui dès le début
et c'est ça qui est frappant à mon avis
a dans cette dimension de de autoritaire
de verticalité qui est un mot d'ailleurs
qui l'emploie lui-même restaurer la
verticale du pouvoir et même dans une
composante quand même très forte de
violence la base de son pouvoir parce
que François Hollande est-ce que cette
opposition entre les démocrates les les
hommes d'État démocrates qui veulent
être aimé et les hommes d'État les
autocrates qui veulent être craints et
respectés est-ce que ça vous paraît une
grille de lecture donc vous avez fait
l'expérience le démocrate va faire tout
pour convaincre l'autoritaire qu'ils
sont finalement très proches que les
valeurs que l'un exprime peuvent être
partagées par l'autre
l'autoritaire ou le dictateur lui
regarde le démocrate en sachant qu'il
est là que pour quelques jours quelques
semaines quelques mois et que ce qu'il
dit à une importance toute relative et
ce qui va compter c'est la durée et
c'est la force donc il faut que le
démocrate s'il veut faire son métier son
travail de responsable de son pays
peut-être aussi du sort du monde et
conscience que tout est rapport de force
et que face à un dictateur la séduction
le plaisir à sympathie tout ça n'a
aucune valeur
l'autre élément c'est l'autre élément
donc que vous décrivez de la stratégie
du pouvoir de de Poutine c'est
l'élimination c'est l'autocrate c'est
l'élimination le poids personnel c'est
l'élimination de tous ceux qui l'ont
aidé des réseaux ski mais dont il ne
veut pas être l'obligé vous raconter les
mésaventures de cette oligarque ou de
tous ceux qui ont suffisamment de
puissance
Codo Rohff
kowski pardon qui a trop de puissance et
qu'il élimine donc il fait rouler la
tête dans la sueur pour que ça soit un
spectacle pour le peuple donc c'est
l'autocratie comme système de
gouvernement oui
bien c'est d'ailleurs un spectacle que
donnait déjà Staline à son peuple
c'est-à-dire quand les chemins de fer ne
fonctionnaient pas en Union soviétique
sa ligne convoquait le chef des chemins
de fer lui faisait un procès politique
très public et finalement lui faisait
confesser qu'il avait qu'il avait saboté
les chemins de fer le faisait fusiller
ça ne donnait pas solution au problème
des chemins de fer mais ça donnait un
excitoires quand même à la colère de
tous ceux qui qui n'étaient pas contents
pour pour l'état des transports
soviétiques alors ce cette opération
dont vous parlez a donc deux avantages
d'un côté on élimine des puissances
rivales d'un autre côté on offre le
spectacle de puissants qui tombent qui
sont traînés dans la bon et dans le
Carrus d'ailleurs quelquefois qui qui
meurt aussi et ça a été la compagnie
électorale de de Poutine de 2004 il l'a
fait comme ça il y a un troisième
élément c'est l'idéologie une idéologie
ultra conservatrice réactionnaire ultra
identitaire les mannes de la vieille
brussie les valeurs de la religion
traditionnelle liste de
orthodoxe
l'ordre stalingien la détestation de
l'Occident des cadons et puis un truc
très très fort que vous évoquez qui est
le sentiment de la l'humiliation prendre
sa revanche contre l'humiliation dans la
Russie pense-t-il à été l'objet
notamment à partir de la désagrégation
du bloc soviétique des années 90 c'est
le moteur en tout cas c'est le moteur du
discours de légitimation du pouvoir
voilà je pense que Poutine en vérité
n'est pas un idéologue ne pas un homme
d'été l'idée c'est un animal politique
de pouvoir pur et brutale donc son
discours peut changer évolué le passage
de medvedef dont on parlait Monsieur
Hollande est un passage crucial parce
que à ce moment-là
euh quand mesdev doit céder la place à
Poutine euh une partie des élites
pré-oxydantes et notamment à Moscou à
Saint-Pétersbourg se rebelle et c'est
une forme de bourgeoisie qui avait été
d'ailleurs en partie créée par les
années de booméconomique de
relatifs stabilité et tout ça qui a
envie que mes vedette reste et que
Poutine ne revienne pas et à ce
moment-là en effet Poutine parvient à
revenir parce que en effet l'attitude de
mettre vedev lui-même n'est pas
extraordinairement
agressive ou et quand il revient son
discours a changé c'est à dire que là il
estime qu'il a été un peu trahi par ses
élites plutôt pro-occidentales les plus
et il va revenir avec un discours qui va
être là du coup vraiment la défense de
la tradition le retour à la
d'une certaine façon à l'ancienne Union
soviétique
après c'est un mix hein la puissance
russe c'est une combinaison très bizarre
de de on a des gens qui sont tatoués sur
sur la même sur une épaule avec le
symbole soviétique sur l'autre le tsar
et puis la croix orthodoxe tout ce qui
exprime d'une façon ou de l'autre la
puissance et le rang de la Russie sur la
scène mondiale François Hollande vous
avez rencontré à nombreuses reprises
Poutine vous avez négocié avec lui
travailler avec lui ou contre lui vous
en faites un portrait d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises dans votre livre vous
le comparez même à Trump vous vous
reconnaissez le Poutine réel que vous
avez rencontré dans le Poutine de
fiction que Juliano a écrit
oui c'est très troublant d'ailleurs que
Giuliano qui n'a jamais rencontré
Poutine
puisse avoir perçu exactement non pas
simplement le trade personnalité que
l'on peut d'ailleurs imaginer à la
télévision non le système de Poutine et
cette rupture de 2012 qui est très
importante c'est pour ça que je commence
mon livre par 2012 et le retour de
Poutine au Kremlin parce que c'est un
autre Poutine qui arrive à Poutine qui a
été doublement frustré frustré d'avoir
perdu une partie du pouvoir frustré
d'avoir vu la Russie déclinée prend-il
pendant cette période parce que
belvédère a laissé l'intervention
américaine anglaise française en Libye
qu'il s'est abstenu au Conseil de
sécurité pour lui c'est une faute
majeure donc il est là et il veut
prendre sa revanche parce que c'est
c'était exactement ce ce que j'ai perçu
moi la première rencontre un homme qui
avait déjà eu la verticalité du pouvoir
mais qui cette fois-ci allait l'utiliser
non pas pour ouvrir son pays pour le
moderniser pour faire que il y ait un
partage de la rente pétrolière au profit
de ses proches pas seulement là il
s'agissait de faire revenir la Russie
sans idéologie c'est à dire reconstituer
l'Union soviétique sans le communisme
mais avec les méthodes du stalinisme
c'est ça le projet et le le but de
Poutine c'est-à-dire de reconstituer ce
qui a été l'Empire et de le faire avec
les méthodes traditionnelles celles
qu'on plier les arbres puisque vous
l'appelez ainsi comme comme les
dirigeants soviétiques Staline pas
Lénine parce que Lénine est un idéologue
Staline et simplement l'homme qui va
utiliser la force jusqu'au bout et c'est
pour ça que la comparaison toujours de
la dédézaification pour ça il utilise
toujours les mots nazis parce que c'est
fait partie de ce que
Staline a laissé comme leg à la Russie
et à l'Union soviétique donc c'est très
intéressant que de l'extérieur vous ayez
perçu cela alors que beaucoup de ceux
qui étaient à l'intérieur je ne vais pas
dans ce dans cette catégorie continuer à
regarder Poutine comme si c'était
toujours le même non c'était plus le
même il avait une intention qui n'était
plus simplement de se faire accepter par
les grandes du les grandes puissances du
monde c'était maintenant de devenir avec
la Chine avec laquelle il nous une
alliance la première puissance du monde
vous analysez d'ailleurs dans
bouleversement la stratégie allemande de
ce point de vue et vous la vous
l'évaluez disons bouleversement c'est
donc le livre que vous publiez vous
livrez une analyse sur les désordres du
monde très clair très précis très
pédagogique c'est en plus très vivant
parce que c'était maillé de portraits
certains sympathiques Angela Merkel vous
a beaucoup plu manifestement par sa
modestie à persévérance à minutie aussi
d'autres d'être plus moins à même Obama
par exemple on sent en filigrane que
vous le trouvez un peu arrogant et
indécis vous n'êtes pas très aimable
avec votre successeur mais ça c'est à la
fois sans doute injuste mais de bonne
guerre compréhensible mais l'essentiel
ne semble-t-il ce sont vos analyses et
notamment vous vous
analysez une
un frottement de deux plaques
tectoniques qui créent le désordre dans
lequel nous sommes
l'Occident qui se replie et l'Orient
entre guillemets qui sont Hardy à
l'ouest aux États-Unis Europe la
tentation isolationniste le
souverainisme le scepticisme et à l'Est
Russie Chine Iran Turquie la tentation
impériale et c'est ça qui selon vous
crée l'essentiel du désordre mondial oui
nous nous avons vécu une décennie et
nous allons peut-être en vivre une autre
qui est marqué par la montée des
nationalismes mais de sorte de
nationalisme le nationalisme si je puis
dire à l'est c'est un nationalisme de
conquête
la Russie veut reprendre ce qui était
son espace la Chine veut reconquérir ce
qui était son histoire pas simplement
Taïwan mais la mère de Chine est
peut-être au-delà l'Iran veut redevenir
l'empire perse la Turquie redevenir
l'Empire
ottoman donc c'est un nationalisme avec
des régimes autoritaires dictatoriaux
qui poussent pour être maintenant dans
dans les dynamiques dans une domination
et en face on a un autre nationalisme on
pourrait dire populiste isolationniste
qui dit mais non c'est chez nous que ça
doit se passer on doit s'enfermer Trump
en a été une des manifestations mais on
en a bien d'autres d'une certaine façon
ce qui s'est passé en Italie c'est de
dire bon on va s'enfermer il y a du
désordre partout il y a des migrants qui
arrivent essayons de vivre sans que nous
soyons d'une certaine mesure
bousculée bouleversée par précisément ce
qui se passe dans le monde ici en France
l'extrême droite vit de cela et on le
voit aussi dans les pays de de l'Europe
en disant essayons de vivre le plus
tranquille possible sauf que il y a une
menace qui maintenant apparue de ce
point de vue à la guerre en Ukraine
vient créer un fait nouveau c'est
précisément ce qu'on redoutait ou ce
qu'on pensait être impossible et bien
vient de se produire donc il y a deux
attitudes possibles et on va les voir
s'exprimer dans les prochaines semaines
ou d'aller prochain mois de dire écoutez
face à ces ambitions conquérantes et
assez menaces autoritaires nous devons
nous les démocraties nous organiser et
répondre de manière responsable mais
avec des alliances et une cohérence et
puis une autre attitude qui va devenir
écouter si c'est pour quelques
kilomètres carrés de de territoires
Ukrainiens ou de savoir si Taïwan doit
revenir à la Chine
[Musique]
populaire est-ce que ça vaut bien la
peine de payer plus cher son essence
d'avoir un chauffage qui est de plus en
plus difficile à payer est-ce que ça
vaut la peine d'avoir une récession
d'avoir de l'inflation est-ce qu'on
serait pas mieux en se séparant de tout
ce monde dangereux et instable mais
c'est d'ailleurs moi la conclusion que
j'ai tiré en vous lisant c'est que je me
suis dit mais bon sang il y a une seule
chose à faire mais tout de suite c'est
que les 7 8 9 pays européens grandes
puissances se fusionnent et Lise un
président universel mais une seule
politique étrangère une seule politique
commerciale une seule politique de
défense parce que les États-Unis se
retirent les dangers sont devant nous
alors vous évoquez mais fugacements
enfin vous évoquez ce que vous appelez
le sauf fédéral s'agissant de la défense
elle vous dites il faut qu'on avance
mais vous croyez pas que pour la
génération pour votre génération
d'hommes publics comme il y a deux ou
trois générations on a construit la
Communauté européenne l'urgence des
urgences c'est de créer une vraie des
États-Unis d'Europe oui mais si on
commence par les institutions on est
perdu on a connu ça dans
mystique est-ce que nous nous sommes
prêts si les Américains un jour se
retiraient car eux aussi sont pris par
la convulsion isolationniste et
nationaliste Biden s'il n'y avait pas eu
la guerre en Ukraine est-ce qu'on est
sûr qu'il serait resté présent sur la
scène de Robin vous avez cité Obama
Obama était dans une logique ou je
pouvais la comprendre on se retire
progressivement du champ international
et bien si un jour les États-Unis ne
sont plus là est-ce que nous sommes
prêts nous défendre est-ce que ce temps
long de la construction progressive par
le bas et compatible avec le temps court
des menaces les menaces impériales et
puis vous avez ok aussi les menaces
transnationales le réchauffement
climatique la prolifération nucléaire
les désordres monétaires qui requiert
une action immédiate du continent
européen il y a pas une contradiction
non il y a pas de contradiction
l'Europe elle est quand même pour nous
le levier principal y compris par
rapport à l'action climatique y compris
même pour faire la transition
énergétique s'il y a pas l'Europe est-ce
que les pays qui sont endettés je ne
veux pas mettre l'Italie en
cible mais la France l'est aussi est-ce
que les pays pourront assurer cette
reconversion industrielle cette mutation
des modes de vie des transports sans
avoir l'appui financier de l'Europe
c'est à ce moment-là d'ailleurs que les
souverainistes et les nationalistes sont
pris à leur propre piège le climat il
connaît pas de frontières la
prolifération nucléaire s'il y a un
incident dans une centrale en Ukraine
elle s'arrêtera pas comme un Tchernobyl
on l'avait pensé à la frontière de de
l'Est de l'Europe donc tout est mondial
et il faut toujours penser que un
événement qui se passe dans le monde
aura nécessairement une conséquence sur
notre propre vie je me souviens d'un
Conseil européen il y avait peut-être
déjà ma théorie où j'ai dit voyez
c'était en 2013 qu'est-ce qui se passe
en Syrie vous fermez les yeux vous
laissez Bachar el-Assad utilise l'herbe
chimiques vous laissez les Russes
bombarder se préparer d'ailleurs
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle David j'ai 22 ans
je suis étudiant en Master dans une
école de commerce à Paris et je fais mon
alternance dans une boîte de production
audiovisuelle il y a beaucoup de choses
qui me passionnent dans la vie donc je
porte de l'intérêt pour le sport la
musique la lecture et je fais partie
d'une famille où il y a pas mal de
grands lecteurs donc on a l'habitude
souvent de s'acheter et de s'offrir pas
mal de livres j'aimerais vous parler
d'un ouvrage qui n'est pas récent mais
qui m'a vraiment beaucoup marqué cet
ouvrage c'est le problème Spinoza de
Irvin et à l'homme qui a été publié il y
a une dizaine d'années mais qui pour moi
est vraiment amené à devenir un
classique
c'est la biographie romancée de deux
êtres que tout sépare d'un côté on a
Spinoza le philosophe juif qu'on peut
suivre dans sa pensée dans sa vie
quotidienne et de l'autre l'idéologue
nazi Alfred Rosenberg qui va être le
responsable du massacre de population
juive mais qui est fascinée par Spinoza
donc c'est un livre facile à lire malgré
le caractère sérieux de son sujet et
très inspirant ma question s'adresse à
vous monsieur le Président votre livre
bouleversement m'a beaucoup intéressé et
j'ai apprécié notamment les portraits
savoureux que vous faisiez de vos
homologues chef d'État dirigeants
étrangers que ça soit Poutine Angela
Merkel Obama Jean Ping et vous évoquez
une rencontre aussi avec Elon Musk qui a
comme projet on le sait la colonisation
de l'espace et j'aimerais savoir si ce
projet vous paraît être de la
science-fiction ou si on peut imaginer
un monde de demain ou les états
deviendraient comme vous écrivez des
objets de musée
en effet dans le livre il y a quelques
portraits savoureux quelques il y a un
échange téléphonique avec Trump je
laisse le lecteur le soin de découvrir
et puis il y a cet échange avec Elon
Musk où vous avez l'air enfin on sent
votre votre curiosité plus ou moins
sceptique alors nous devons être en 2014
fin 2014 je fais un voyage
aux États-Unis une visite d'État et puis
je vais forcément dans la Silicon Valley
je rencontre les les grands
géants du numérique il y en a un qui me
dit je veux voir à part et c'est Elon
Musk Elon Musk qui déjà s'est fait
connaître par
une percée dans le monde des satellites
il est très grande et je découvre un
homme tout à fait délié de tout
qui me présente un monde qui est celui
de voyage possible sur Mars de de
pouvoir être éternel ce qui est quand
même
par rapport à ce qui est notre angoisse
est toujours
passionnant et je me dis mais c'est cet
homme là qui est le plus riche du monde
il l'est qui va peut-être racheter
Twitter et d'autres entreprises et qui a
cette vision où il n'y a plus d'État il
n'y a plus de peuple il n'y a que des
objets et une espèce de
transhumanisation je ne dis pas de
déshumanisation de transhumanisation où
on voit bien qu'il y aurait une petite
partie de la population qui pourrait
vivre justement sur une autre planète
débarrassée de guerre débarrasser du
réchauffement climatique et l'autre la
ville multitude nous serions peut-être
dedans ou il nous ferait une forêt
accepter ce royaume des objets
alors on ne peut pas inviter tous les
auteurs mais on peut parler d'un certain
nombre de livres et donc je vais vous
demander d'abord Giuliano quel est le
livre de la semaine en tout cas le livre
que vous avez lu et que vous avez envie
de recommander à nos lecteurs attention
c'est satisfait au remboursé hein ils
doivent être vraiment content de ce que
vous leur proposez à lire ça s'appelle
palimpsesses c'est un roman assez
extraordinaire qui raconte le parcours
d'un encore une fois d'un
communicant national populiste dans un
régime qu'il appelle national
consumériste qui a une invention assez
intéressante et ce personnage doit
propager de des faux des uns des fausses
informations faire de la désinformation
mais en même temps il est à la recherche
de ces vrais origines familiales et donc
il vit un peu ce qui se Venise d'être
d'être au milieu de ces de ces deux
parcours c'est un roman de la de la
rentrée j'ai oublié vraiment le nom de
l'auteur mais c'est très brillant et
vous monsieur le Président quel est le
livre qui vous inspire il y a un livre
que j'ai redécouvert je l'avais lu quand
j'avais 17 ans et qui correspond assez
bien à ce que vous décrivez vous-même du
système poutinien qui est le 0 et
l'infini d'Alfred custler et qui m'avait
beaucoup marqué voilà et je recommande
de lire ce livre parce que on a le
sentiment que c'est de l'histoire non
c'est de l'actualité on l'avait on
l'avait mis au chapitre des livres que
nous nous allons recommandé parce que
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre d'un type génial
qui a été un agent du communisme et qui
dans les années 40 écrit ça c'est le
bréviaire que tout le monde doit lire
pour comprendre quelle est la folie
quand on transforme l'idéal en idéologie
en religion à l'heure où fleurissent les
radicalisme c'est vraiment je
m'apprêtais à vous l'offrir mais non je
vais l'offrir à jouer l'anneau John Le
Carré c'est un livre posthume et là
encore si un romancier a bien montré
qu'on pouvait interpréter le monde à
travers la fiction c'est bien lui c'est
un roman posthume mais c'est un vrai
roman je confesse ce que je ne l'ai pas
lu mais il est paraît-il fantastique je
suis sûr que ça va vous intéresser ça
c'est une bande dessinée un roman
graphique slavas et dans notre thème
parce que c'est
ce qui se passe en Russie poste
soviétisme raconté par la voix d'une
bande dessinée je vous sens happé par
l'envie de le lire et enfin Julia
Minkowski Liza Vignoli l'avocate était
une femme c'est le poche de la semaine
c'est le portrait de on dit on n'a pas
de mots pour ténor c'est dire à quel
point le barreau a été sexiste longtemps
ténora Distel voilà c'est le portrait de
des avocats d'aujourd'hui qui sont
d'excellentes
membres du Barreau il y a d'ailleurs un
documentaire très bien fait on les
interroge et qui est diffusé sur Public
Sénat
voilà cette émission est terminée mais
le temps de la lecture commence pour
vous si vous voulez je remercie et
Juliano daopoly et François Hollande qui
nous ont permis de voir le monde l'un à
travers les yeux d'un leader occidental
et l'autre à travers les yeux d'un tyran
oriental je remercie notre lecteur David
zuf je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi
si vous voulez revoir cette émission
vous pouvez le faire sur le site de
Public Sénat ou bien en podcast au
plateforme préférée et puis nous nous
retrouvons la semaine prochaine même
chaîne même heure peut-être que d'ici là
nous nous serons croisés dans une
librairie merci beaucoup et bonsoir
[Musique]